Hola a todos, hoy vamos a desmenuzar un cambio radical que está a punto de sacudir Chile.
Hablamos de la nueva ley de protección de datos, la famosa ley 21719, pero nos vamos
a enfocar en algo súper específico y, francamente de altísimo voltaje, las nuevas reglas para
los organismos del Estado.
Ojo, porque esto es una transformación absoluta, pasamos de un modelo que ya estaba pidiendo
a gritos una actualización a un estándar de primerísimo nivel internacional, así
que vamos a ello.
Bueno, esta es nuestra hoja de ruta para hoy.
Empezaremos viendo la nueva era de la privacidad, luego esa excepción del consentimiento en
el sector público, pasaremos a las reglas de transparencia obligatoria, después a esa
brutal responsabilidad económica personal de la que hablábamos y cerraremos con el
nuevo estándar estatal.
¡Arrancamos!
Punto número uno, la nueva era de la privacidad.
A ver, para perdernos en situación, esta ley básicamente alinea Chile con el estándar
europeo.
Y ojo al dato, crea una nueva agencia de protección de datos.
Con dientes de verdad.
Para el sector privado, la cosa se pone seria.
Tratar datos ahora exige un consentimiento libre, informado, específico e inequívoco.
Se acabó eso de las casillas pre-marcadas por defecto.
Y si alguien se salta las normas, pues hablamos de multas gigantescas de hasta 20.000 unidades
tributarias mensuales.
Pero, y aquí viene lo fascinante, el Estado juega con un manual de reglas que está literalmente
del revés.
Pasamos al punto dos, la excepción de consentimiento en el sector público.
Si nos fijamos en este contraste, la verdad es que es brutal.
Por un lado, tenemos a las empresas privadas sudando la gota gorda para conseguir un consentimiento
explícito y rastreable.
Por el otro, los organismos estatales.
Ellos pueden, sencillamente, saltarse el consentimiento por completo.
La condición, que el tratamiento de esos datos cumpla un mandato legal dentro de sus
competencias.
Básicamente, la ley reconoce que el Estado necesita cierta agilidad para funcionar.
Pero claro, esto le otorga un nivel de acceso a nuestra información que es extraordinario.
Hablamos de un auténtico régimen de licitud del sector público sin consentimiento del
titular.
Para entenderlo mejor, echemos un vistazo a la redacción exacta del artículo 20.
Es literalmente la llave que le da al Estado este superpoder.
Este texto elimina de un plumazo la barrera del consentimiento ciudadano.
Si la institución pública está actuando dentro de sus funciones legales, bingo, el
uso de la información es totalmente válido.
No tienen que pedir permiso.
Y eso nos lleva al punto tres, las reglas de transparencia obligatoria.
Claro, como el Estado tiene vía libre sin necesidad de pedir permiso, el legislador
tuvo que pisar el freno en el artículo 22.
Los organismos pueden compartir nuestros datos internamente, sí, de manera muy fluida,
por ejemplo, para darnos beneficios sociales o simplemente para evitar el típico papeleo
de tráigame el mismo documento 20 veces.
Pero, y este es un pero gigante, están obligadísimos a eliminar o anonimizar esos datos en el
instante en que esa tarea específica termine.
Eso de guardar datos por si acaso, en el sector público, se ha terminado.
Veamos cómo funciona esto en la práctica, paso a paso.
El paso uno es superágil.
El intercambio interno dentro del Estado no requiere consentimiento.
Ahora, el paso dos.
Si el Estado quiere pasar esos datos al sector privado, freno de mano.
Ahí sí que se exige nuestro consentimiento, a menos que sea para temas de fiscalización.
Y el paso tres, que es la verdadera joya de la corona en cuanto a control.
La publicación de absolutamente todos los convenios de transferencia.
Y quiero recalcar este texto literal, porque es importantísimo.
Hablamos de la obligatoriedad de publicar convenios de cesión de datos.
Las agencias públicas tienen que informar mes a mes sobre estos acuerdos directamente en sus páginas web.
Es más, la nueva Agencia de Protección de Datos va a estar ahí, con lupa en mano,
vigilando que este nivel de transparencia mensual se cumpla sin ninguna excusa.
Vamos al plato fuerte, el punto cuatro.
La responsabilidad económica personal.
Aquí es donde la ley de verdad enseña los dientes.
Pensemos en esto un momento.
Históricamente, si el Estado metía la pata, la multa salía del propio presupuesto estatal.
O sea, movían dinero público.
De un cajón a otro, y listo.
Bueno, pues esta ley dinamita por completo ese paradigma.
Ahora establece una responsabilidad que no va dirigida al organismo como si fuera un ente abstracto sin rostro,
que va, a punta, directa y personalmente, al jefe superior del órgano público.
En caso de infracciones graves, atención a esto, la multa va del 20 al 50 por ciento,
y se aplica directamente sobre el sueldo mensual del jefe de la agencia.
Literalmente, el dinero sale del bolsillo del directivo.
Esta responsabilidad personal directiva sobre las remuneraciones es, sin duda,
uno de los incentivos más bestias y agresivos que jamás han escrito en la legislación chilena
para asegurar que las cosas se hagan bien.
Claro, el porcentaje exacto que va a desaparecer de esa nómina no es aleatorio.
Depende de cosas como la gravedad de la brecha,
los sensibles que sean los datos,
imaginemos que se filtre información médica o biométrica, gravísimo,
y, por supuesto, cuántos ciudadanos resulten afectados.
También se tiene en cuenta si la persona intentó mitigar el daño.
Vamos, que esto obliga a las instituciones públicas a montar una cultura de prevención de riesgos
absolutamente extrema.
Y, finalmente, el punto 5.
Un nuevo estándar estatal.
A modo de resumen, estamos ante un acto de malabarismo legal increíble de cara a diciembre de 2026,
que es cuando esto entra en vigor.
Por un lado, tenemos este inmenso poder del Estado para procesar y ceder datos sin nuestro consentimiento.
Pero, por el otro, la balanza se equilibra con un riesgo financiero personal sin precedentes para sus líderes
y esa transparencia mensual obligatoria.
Es un sistema diseñado al milímetro para que el Estado sea eficiente, sí,
pero sin pasar por encima de nuestra privacidad.
Así que nos queda una gran pregunta en el aire.
Con esta regla sobre la mesa, ¿será suficiente esta tremenda amenaza al bolsillo personal de los directivos
para garantizar por fin la seguridad de nuestros datos dentro del Estado?
La verdadera respuesta la empezaremos a ver a partir de 2026,
cuando este famoso artículo 44 entre en acción.
Desde luego, es un escenario apasionante al que no le vamos a quitar el ojo de encima.
Muchísimas gracias por acompañarnos en este análisis.